[Music]
welcome to the fourth lecture of the
lecture serious Godin Computers Minds
machines and metaphysics we had the
first lecture was about the human factor
given by Paul Penfield then we heard
about animals by mark house or animals
and consciousness animal and ethics last
week we heard about brains and how brain
function and where spirituality might be
localized in them or might be able to
localize them and today now we hear
about robotics before we can start about
that just predictably one thing if you
happen to have this pro shoe I have also
some left the meetings discussion
meetings at Harvard Divinity School the
first one is on Monday at 12 o'clock at
Harvard Divinity School 45 Francis
Avenue run by Harvey Cox and me so yeah
very welcome to bring your questions and
discussions you cannot address today to
this discussion group on Monday the
other dates you will all find in that
little brochure and now I'm very pleased
and happy to welcome Rodney Brooks and
with the introduction is always a little
bit difficult if you actually have to
introduce your own boss so I am kind of
I'm not quite sure how to do that but
rod is currently the director of the
artificial intelligence lab here at MIT
he holds a PhD in computer science from
Stanford where was mostly interested in
vision and when he came to MIT in 1981
he was still mostly interested in
classical AI problems but slowly his
focus began to shift since AI had failed
to reach its goal of human-like
intelligent machines rod broke with most
assumptions of the his field and started
in you based on the work of mater Anna
and Varela Barilla by the way will give
his talk in two weeks here rod started
to perceive intelligence as being in the
world as interaction as embodiment he
then built creatures
insect-like robots which were far better
than anything else which had been built
before in navigating an unstructured
world and natural environments for his
work he received numerous awards became
1996 a fellow in the American
Association of the Advancement of
science and is today accepted at so
called father of embodied AI and
recently he even became a movie star his
his movie fast cheap and out of control
named after a research paper of his is
currently run running at Kendall theatre
and I can only highly recommend to all
to go there right latest attempt to
rebuild intelligent creatures goes a
little bit beyond insects hence the type
title of his table paper artificial
humanity and so I'm very happy and glad
and pleased to welcome you here I
[Applause]
normally give even less technical detail
than the normal and the title is
artificial humanity but it's a nonlinear
talk because to be honest I couldn't
figure out how to fill up a whole hour
so I've got some little diversions along
the way which are necessarily straight
along the line here but the question is
to me whether we can ever have humanity
in robots whether we can think of them
in the same way we think of other humans
and that's all tied up with lots of
beliefs we have and lots of insecurities
we have another in the last few hundred
years we've we've seen mankind's retreat
from specialness Galileo well another's
around there let us know that the earth
was no longer the center of the universe
and so we went this piece of rock that
were standing on wasn't particularly
special and in Darwin came along and we
saw that humans and
animals have common ancestors they're
not their origins are not that different
Crick and Watson DNA and the mechanism
of life means that humans and yeast are
pretty similar and he sees sort of we're
treating here from all these special
things and each of these retreats has
been has been met by a lot of argument
and a lot of fear and you know as you
get further and further down here and as
you get further and further south in the
u.s. you know not everyone is accepted
all these things you know and then if
you look at back in the in the middle of
the 50s men schema McCarthy knew old
Simon etc human thought is the same as
computation ensuring of course human
thought is the same as computation and
hence fits on machine so there was a you
know the thought process the logic
process was sort of taken away from us
and as we've understood biochemistry
better and better we find that we're
collections of tiny machines and and
we're where the essence of humanity is
you know it's it's harder and harder to
find and very recently just this year
you know we start to see that human
flesh and body plans are subject to
technological manipulation just over the
weekend or yeah I think whether we can
though the stories about the headless
frogs that were grown in in England and
then a whole raft of news stories at
Lewis Wolpert at Bell London responded
to about whether we could now start
building headless humans as a way of
growing new organs and and all the the
fears that that that produced so we're
sort of retreating to be less and less
special and each of those retreats comes
with with quite a quite a bit of
consternation quite a bit of argument
and the one I want to talk about today
is whether robots can feel loved and
since God is in the title of this and
worship and have souls
so as an appointed out I've been playing
with humanoid robots recently and this
is a version of our robot cog from a
little while back they'll hear that AI
lab
and our goal was to build a robot that
that develops an axe in the world in the
same way that humans develop and act in
the world and and why human well we we
wanted to have it to have similar
sensory motor experiences very much
influenced by Mark Johnson and who's got
Berkley women fire and dangerous things
lake off etcetera but you know III have
to admit this is this this particular
motivation is the one that worries me
most the one that makes me think the moe
maybe we're engaged in in in this
exercise and a bit of cargo cult science
do people know about the cargo cults in
New Guinea this is one of little
diversions anyone not know about the
cargo cults
okay so during the Second World War that
both the Allied troops and the Japanese
troops had lots of fighting going on in
New Guinea and they would come and
they'd clear out some land and build a
control tower and then these silver
Birds would come down and disgorge lots
of supplies and so after all the troops
left a lot of the native tribes started
flattening out areas of land building
bamboo control towers and sitting up
there waiting for these silver birds to
come down from the sky and so I do worry
a little bit that in building this robot
with to have similar sensory motor
experiences maybe where you're engaging
in that sort of cargo as it's
called because it doesn't really have a
lot of the stuff that humans have but
one thing that has certainly turned out
to be true is that humans interact with
these robots in natural sorts of ways
they can't help themselves
we seem and this is not something we've
studied in great detail so it's it's
rather anecdotal and I'll only give
anecdotal instance incidents today but
humans just can't help but interact with
these machines that look like humans in
human-like ways and that I think is the
key the question of answering whether
robots will eventually have souls and
that's what I'm going to try and get to
today people just find themselves
interacting with it like a human
let me show you the first video just
that just to show you you know cog doing
some stuff and compared to Star Wars
movies it's a little disappointing but
it took us a long time okay so I'm
supposed to Kris
okay so here you see that this is an old
version has come forward my head up
there
it's putting things in its hand it's
attracted by the motion it's looking at
things we've built the arms with the
series elastic actuators about my girl
Pratt and Matt Williamson which your
neighbor was to interact with this robot
this is a the head system you see the
ISO carding from place to place we're
rapidly about human speeds as a
wide-angle lens and narrow angle lens in
each eye this is scouting to motion you
see the eyes rapidly moving from place
to place this is a smooth pursuit where
the eyes are smoothly following
something these are all the basic sorts
of visual operations that people do you
can't move your eyes smoothly from side
to side unless you've got something to
track it turns out this is the
vestibular system simulating the inner
ears here it's not switched on as we
move the head around the eyes just
waggle around all over the place when we
switch on the inner ears now the eyes
are stabilized as we move the head
unpredictably and we take walked onto
one position that's very important to
you to stabilize your vision now here
you see the eyes Sicard somewhere and
then the next tries to get the eyes back
into roughly the center of their range
of motion and the efferent copy signal
is sent to the eyes to compensate for
the motion when we put this in the robot
started to feel much more human the way
it looked at us
here's Matt Williamson designer this is
with his old arm just showing some basic
infant-like reflexes withdrawal reflex
feels the touch and pulls its arm back
you know infants have the grasp reflex
withdrawal reflex etc and in order for
Matt to get his master's thesis I made
improve that the arm was safe to
interact with
and this is this is some new arms and
we've got a bunch of new stuff with this
but I'm not going to show that today
it's not relevant this is a tape we made
up for triple-a I a couple of months ago
let's show you some physical coupling
through the system the body is important
as with with physical bodies of humans
and recently matters had playing with
slinkys and like like a curvy feeling
pendulum swinging back and forth this is
a cog learning to reach learning a
hand-eye coordination it's the cards its
eyes to some point and then reaches out
its hand moves its hand to see how well
it got to the center of location of its
eyes and then learns how to move its its
hand so it sits there for a few hours
reaching out the places that looks this
is its point of view you see that
saccade happened in a second and during
this card we have to suppress the motion
detection just like happens in the human
visual system and then it puts his hand
out and it moves its hand around to see
where it's a harm ended up so that can
learn how to operate in the world after
about three hours of learning here Brian
skes alladhi gives it a motion cue it
reaches out the hand was working at this
point and now he's gonna wave what's the
eyes up there and you see the eyes in a
second or two so card over to that
motion there they seconded now it's
gonna try and reach out to that this is
the result of its learning for a few
hours with no prior knowledge of the
kinematics with dynamics or whatever
it's all almond now here's an
interesting case where Cynthia Farrell
one of the designers of the robot was
just trying to engage some motions of
the arm and when we looked at the
videotape we saw that the robot and she
were playing taking turns and we weren't
planning on putting turn-taking into the
robot for quite a while but she is a
even as a non naive observer couldn't
help but get into that dynamic of
playing up by getting of that that
dynamic of playing a game with the robot
and that's that's gonna be an important
point later on okay
now here I'll do another aside we're
building this this humanoid robot there
are lots of other people building
humanoid robots particularly in Japan
right now it's become quite a quite a
quite an industry and there been some
pretty surprising developments recently
for the robotics people in the world
Honda Motor Corporation has had a secret
a secret project it's just like a James
Bond movie
for ten years developing this robot
called p2 p1 was just a pair of legs
with a box on it it looks pretty weird
but they were completely secretive about
this no one knew what was going on last
October I started hearing a couple of
whiskers and then whispers and then in
December they announced it's a 250
kilogram the first biped that can walk
without a tether but it's mostly
mechatronic rather than AI research at
this point the Mitte Ministry of
International Trade and Industry was
talking about a plan to build lots of
humanoid robots and give them to
universities and Honda didn't want to be
left out of the action given hundred
million dollars into this over ten years
they announced that last December by
about three or four weeks ago they had
their new model out the p2 or p3 sorry
which is smaller weighs about 110
kilograms with a 30 kilogram payload and
so this was this was done in in just 9
or 10 months then I got a hundred people
working on this project building
humanoid robots and Honda has suddenly
become a major robot company in the eyes
of the Japanese public through this
project there's some talk about having
the p2 or p3 at the opening of the world
what'd he call it what's the world
soccer tournament thing World Cup having
it out there on the field kicking the
ball
it won't work if the if the if they'll
ground is soggy by the way because the
algorithms that they use a rather rather
fragile but lots of other people in
Japan are also are also building
humanoid robots this is Waseda
University with a couple of their
humanoids they now have a hundred people
working in a humanoid research
laboratory and there are other humanoid
research laboratories that is ones at
ETL as ones that took your University
the HAARP lab etc so it's become a big
industry there's gonna be lots and lots
more humanoid robots most of these
Japanese robots at this point don't have
much in the way of intelligence or
emotional models etc although one of the
the robots set that masada does have a
model of the amygdala the hippocampus
and and and a whole bunch of the inner
emotional sections of the brain perhaps
they're trying to put that together okay
that was an aside let's get back to
whether we're gonna be able to build
robots with humanity in them whether
we're going to respect them you just saw
a videotape of of our robot but I need
to come clean a little bit and I think
in this in this talk and especially
since I believe I haven't been to any of
the talks previously in the series cuz
I've been out of town but Anna tells me
that at the first talk when Paul
Penfield spoke someone complained that
they wanted to hear what an atheist had
to say well I'm and she pointed that I
was going to be the atheist coming along
the talk so my assumptions ah that we
have that there is a completely
mechanic's mechanistic explanation for
everything in the universe I believe
we're all made up of gazillions and I
chose that word because it just seemed
large
mindless soulless robots molecular
machines the little molecules that
biochemical molecules are these machines
we are made up and robots is then then
it is pointed out and I believe that
every human interaction in principle can
be reduced to such mindless explanations
now is this how I live my life no I
don't live it this way at all I don't I
don't I don't think of my kids as all
were just those little mindless
gazillions of machines I think it was
one big mindless you see but that's not
truth III operate in a totally different
level and you know I must admit I was I
was perplexed for a long time by by
scientists who are also religious I
couldn't for a long time it just didn't
seem to me make sense that someone could
be religious and at the same time be a
scientist I couldn't see that duality
and it was only fairly recently that I
realized that that's exactly what I do I
do
live in this jewel world where I have
this level of explanation but for my
everyday life I operate at a very
different level and although they may
deny it I think all atheists operate
this way and and I think all scientists
operate this way having different
parallel belief systems that they that
they operate with so I'm an atheist but
I'm not I'm not gonna be careful to
choose my words here no I won't use them
okay I'm one of the good atheists okay
now related to this I see that that it
seems to me that most scientists engage
in a certain cultural constructivism all
researchers based their work on some
usually unstated dogmatic beliefs and
and this gets a lot of people upset
because a lot of people believe that
they're in search of truth and there is
one truth but I think that when you push
people who speak that way be those who
maybe those beliefs are in the
scientific method which has a certain
religious or or about it when a lot of
people talk about it or whether they
believe as I do that humans ultimately
have mechanistic explanations and when
it gets down to it we can't explain it
beyond that in an illogical way we base
our scientific lives on some set of
assumptions and I've observed that
challenges to these implicit beliefs are
often met with hostility and for those
of you have been on the mailing lists
around here certainly saw that with the
announcement of garden computers the the
course that goes along with a series of
talks okay so those two slides are just
sort of saying where I where I come from
in this um oh boy that sounds awful 70s
doesn't it okay so can we have
artificial humanity can we ever build
robots where we people are sort of
machines and as distinct from those sort
of machines we'll all agree that these
robots are things to be empathize with
well whether things we should pity when
appropriate whether we ever be an
appropriate time to pity a robot
actually I did
do you remember was it Robocop before
Robocop sort of got invented they had
this legged machine that that sort of
blew everyone away remember that and
they chased it out and they chased it
down the stairs and it fell down and its
legs were quivering I was building
walking robots at the time I really felt
for that robot anyway anyway so so
whether they whether whether we should
protect these robots when they sir you
know went with you know the bad grade
student is gonna switch it off we should
stop them and ultimately whether they
should equal be equal before the law and
as we all know the before the law is
very different for me equal before our
hearts and that's that's an even bigger
step to get to so can we have artificial
humanity from a religious point of view
I would think if if we had artificial
humanity we would like to say that these
things had souls I can talk about this
as an atheist so I believe in in the
same sense that humans have souls it'll
be impossible to build humanoid robots
that have human level interactions
without them having Souls but I use my
definition of a soul and in the other
which we'll get to a little later and we
won't even have to try to give them
souls they'll just have them and they'll
have them because of the way we feel
about them ok
that's a that's a sort of tricky
question so a simpler question it's kind
of robot be afraid ok now I think I
think people are willing to say we can
make robots act as if they're afraid you
know we've seen robot actors in movies
act as if they're afraid we can make
robots that seem to be afraid we can
make robots that simulate having fear
and a while back people use the same
sorts of caveats when they talked about
reasoning systems in computers but I
think today most AI researchers are
willing to say that robots or programs
can reason about facts they can make
decisions and they can have goals they
this simulate act as if seem similar you
know I've been replaced by can but I'm
not sure that AI researchers in general
are willing to say that robots can be
afraid they because I think AI
researchers are still you know they've
got that specialness you know they've
been pushed back by their own work for
giving up a lot of stuff but that this
visceral fear that we all know and feel
we willing to say that a machine is
gonna have that sort of real visceral
sort of fear is that something oh they
all just seemed how it will just be a
bunch of heaven forbid see programs
doing stuff well what I want to claim is
that the but ultimately the robots will
be viscerally afraid and it's a matter
of us accepting that rather than any
great technological breakthroughs
necessary
Sonne that in a sense this is a little
disappointing talk because I'm not gonna
I'm gonna say we don't need
technological breakthroughs it's sort of
a the ultimate cop-out talk so in I want
to examine a few a few other people who
talk about some of these similar sorts
of issues and they're not exactly this
issue and I think there's some generic
ways in which they go go wrong one way
they go wrong is through an implicit
rejection of mechanistic explanations
when that rejection is often denied but
nevertheless it's there and I'll show
you an example in the minute and they
conserve the specialness of humankind
that way and they rationalize it as a
scientific argument but in fact they're
doing something sneaky there are there
are hi they're getting rid of a
mechanistic explanation but dressing an
episode is a mechanistic explanation
I'll give you an example and the other
thing which is much more common is in
the dark amongst AI researchers this is
an adoption I have a higher mechanism
researchers want to maintain a purely
mechanistic explanation but they can't
face the reductionism the current models
of the universe so they invent or wish
for and I'll show you examples of both
some super mechanism that will be rather
special and we don't know about yet so
that sort of maintains the specialness
of humans ok first case implicit
rejection of Mexican history explanation
the great example is John Searle from
Berkeley so here's John Searle and and
it the web's great I just went out and
looked and I found John saw a picture of
it
he even fit the clipart ok so Searle
makes this argument suppose he's in a
room and he's got some instructions to
follow and someone feeds in a piece of
paper with some Chinese some
on it okay he doesn't know Chinese I
don't know Chinese I found these on the
web - I have no idea what this says
but that fits with the story although
the output had no idea what the output
says it should be related but who knows
anyway so Chinese symbols come in he
follows the rules and that's this is a
question he follows the rules and he
outputs some answer and you know by
following these rules mechanistically
and he says see john searle still
doesn't know Chinese he can act as if he
knows Chinese but it's not the same as
knowing Chinese but what he misses is
that the whole system the whole system
does know Chinese john searle and his
pencil and his paper and his book of
rules and his procedure that he's
running does know Chinese but he wants
the Chinese to be in his head or
otherwise the system doesn't know
Chinese and I think his argument maps
pretty well to the argument that well
horses can can transport things right
but a car can't transport things because
when you look inside a car there's no
place where the transportation is
happening was wheels and there's
gasoline and the engine and there's no
horses there either so you know it can't
be transporting stuff like a horse
transport stuff and this is the same
argument he makes he because he wants to
he wants to find the understanding in a
component but he doesn't insist that the
same thing happens for humans or for
animals because he says there well
animals are animals so recently there
was a TV program where they interspersed
something I said with something Searle
said that interviewed me I didn't know
saw was going to be in the program and I
got me to say that if it walks like a
duck talks like a duck smells like a
duck it's a duck and so said came on
said if it walks like a duck talks like
a duck smells like a duck it ain't a
duck because that's a duck and he says
the same thing about intelligence
intelligence is intelligence it's only
in humans therefore it can't be another
machine see I proved it because he's not
he sort of
flushed away that mechanistic
explanation but he denies that he
flushes of the way roger penrose on the
other hand at oxford he wants everything
to have a mechanistic explanation he
actually misunderstands gödel theorem
and Turing computability and i think he
does that because he wants to maintain
the specialness of humans that humans
can prove theorems that mere machines
can't and if you read his description of
this there is a misunderstanding there
gerald Adelman by the way makes the same
mistake in his analysis of human kind so
this is not uncommon you know looking at
gödel's theorem and saying we're better
than gödel's theorem so his conclusion
is that people can't be computers but he
wants he wants everything to be
mechanistic so people are more
complicated than ordinary machines and
consciousness is mysterious but he
really wants mechanistic explanations so
what's he to do well he's a physicist so
he says well quantum mechanics is more
complicated in northern ordinary physics
and isn't mysterious hey they must be
the same thing and really I don't think
there's anything more in his argument
it's with this wishing for some other
explanation David Chalmers
now it's UC Santa Cruz philosopher comes
out of a slightly different way he talks
about consciousness and he's quite
serious he did he did he did organize
that consciousness extravaganza in
Arizona last year but he's serious
besides that and he talks about mass
force it said our natural physical kinds
you can't reduce them to simple things
they're just things in the universe
they're natural kinds this stuff and his
argument is consciousness is yet another
natural kind it can't be reduced to
something simpler therefore there's no
need or way to explain it
so he's maintained the specialist by
having consciousness as being some
natural kind I you know well it may be
but I sort of doubt it because all other
natural kinds display some sort of
observable interaction so we would
expect if consciousness was a natural
kind of see telekinesis or some
interaction between consciousness and
other stuff
which which which didn't quite fit we
don't see that so I suspect that that's
not gonna work now of course I think
everyone's guilty of this and otherwise
I'll tell you my own version of this my
own folly okay if you look at an
engineered system and you look at
biological system people don't make
mistakes even young kids pretty much
don't make mistakes they get fooled by
some things when they're very young but
but as they get a little older they they
get pretty sophisticated don't make
mistakes and and think that's a live
animal when it's really a robot or
something like that they can make that
distinction robustness is generally
adaptability of the main of performance
it all gives it away so it seems to me
biological systems are still
fundamentally different from almost all
of our engineered systems so my version
of looking for the higher thing is
something I called the juice I really
believe this by the way is there
something different in life is this and
not necess in the normal sense I don't
think we had my belief is we're not
going to have to go outside of currently
physics or chemistry but in the same way
the idea of computation change what we
could think about you know before Turing
came along and formalized computation
you can think about certain things and
after you could think about a whole
bunch more things that notion of
computation wasn't it wasn't a change in
the universe but it enabled us to think
about new things if you took a late 19th
century mathematician you could teach
them the fundamental ideas of
computation in a few days and they
wouldn't be hold in your head saying oh
my god this can't be this is so foreign
to me it wasn't very far and it was just
a another idea that fit on top of 19th
century mathematics but it completely
enabled thinking about how to knowledge
so my version of what we're missing
is is is there some conceptual juice I
call it waiting for us to discover it
some different way of thinking about
organization and processes of complex
systems that are in all these biological
systems are all sorts of different
levels either in at the molecular level
in in the maintenance of a cell there in
the neural level there in at the genetic
level there in at the immunological
some sort of organizing stuff that's in
there so like computers inside
mechatronic devices that's there but we
just haven't got a way of describing a
way of thinking about it so we never
think to put it in our artificial
systems so this is my version of this by
the way when I first talked about this
two years ago in Switzerland that I had
a workshop that night a graduate student
from Oxford I was sitting at the dinner
table with me and he said oh yeah I
wasn't surprised to see you talk that
way today in the talk I think that's a
sort of ideas a lot of scientists have
when they're in the sunset of their
career
okay so that was an aside that last one
where am I going
let's let's go back a couple slides
where am I getting to and getting to
what will it take for us to be willing
to say that robots can be afraid they
can be viscerally afraid and and I gave
those examples of what I think is
wrongheaded thinking to see where we
might go wrong in thinking about that
now one thing it seems to me that if
we're really going to be thinking about
robots being afraid and I had to have
some sort of models of emotions if we
don't empathize with robots we may need
to be able to identify physically with
them and you know that's why I built
this human shaped robot but we may need
to be able to identify emotionally with
them
- so can robots have emotions and
there's been quite a bit of work many
people in this room have done work on
this in putting emotions into robots or
at least into agent software angels and
I just want to go through and briefly
recap what I think sort of three
different versions of emotional model
surface level emotions subsurface
emotions and emergent emotions and three
different ways of putting emotions into
systems this
surface emotional models seem less
satisfying somehow in terms of things
having visceral emotions visceral
feelings the primitive types are
directly the emotions you know happiness
is a number
Jim Albus even had love as a 4-bit
number in a paper and system man in
cybernetics only a couple of years ago
and then external events excited the
press certain emotional levels these
sorts of models have been around since
the sixties by the way and there may be
lateral inhibition mechanism so that you
can't be happy and sad at the same time
if you're really happy it pushes sadness
down if you really say that it pushes
happiness down etc and then the son
external reflection of the surface
emotions in fact that's me
maybe all there is and that's that's
what this emotional model is it's just
the surface model in the subsurface
models here there are some inner drives
and needs that are the fundamental types
and the emotions sort of come out of
those inner drives and needs being
satisfied or not so the level of
satisfaction of these drives or needs
determines the mood or emotional state
of the system and then the emotional
state may excite or inhibit certain
classes of behavior the robots only
change the way it operates and then
there may also be some explicit external
reflections of emotions designed just to
exhibit that to to the external world so
you know what sort of mood your robot is
in you know what sort of behavior is
probably gonna engage in and so you know
how to interact with a robot or software
agent that's you know if it's busy it's
hairy that's you know looking all over
the net for some dumb question you asked
it don't ask it another one right now so
that's the subsurface model and then
there are emergent emotional models
where there are still internal drives
and needs by the way evolution put these
internal drives and needs into us we're
putting them in our robots and changes
in these are reflected in changes in
excitation or inhibition of behaviors of
the robot and this is not aimed that at
showing an emotional response it's aimed
at getting the robot to satisfy the
drives or needs which are directing the
robot to do what it was designed to do
so these these behaviors that get
excited or inhibited are all associated
with a primary mission of the robot
rather than as some explicit external
emotional display so there are no
emotional variables in the sense of
having happiness as a 4-bit number or
whatever there are no explicit external
displays but the observer attributes the
emotions to the system's and these are
these are deeper sorts of models they
have much harder to do and no one's
really I don't think done a successful
one at that level you know here in the
in the lab and around the place various
people are working on versions of this
we have a pet robot this is Cynthia
Farrell's child robot which got eyebrows
and ears and stopped to give them up now
it has lips but I don't have a photo of
that yet to give emotional responses
this is over at my company is robotics a
robot called it which had a very surface
level emotional model and I want to show
you another emotional robot from is
robotics which is sort of a subsurface
almost emergent level emotional model
this is a doll the neat part about this
is we think we can manufacture for very
little money but um let me show you this
this one
[Music]
and you know this is an advertising tape
for the company so it's a little bit of
hype here which yo excuse
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so let you know that that's all
implemented on an 8-bit processor it's
not it's a it's not a lot of computation
behind there but it but it's engaging at
some level of having this emotional
model so why have these emotional models
gives humans feedback and perhaps other
animals gives them feedback you know
maybe the dog wants to know when the
garbage robot is in a bad mood and
should keep out of the way there's an
intuitive high-level feedback on what
the machine is trying to do currently
what its current set of goals are likely
to be that's the surface level but also
inside provides a mechanism for focusing
the behavior of the machine in some
coherent way when it's it's got lots of
competing pressures that's trying to do
and you know this is not too dissimilar
from DiMaggio's talk about the frontal
lobes etc let me show you another
videotape just to show you how how the
important message here is that the
observer can really get it can get
sucked in fairly easily I think
this is cog again and this is work of
robert erie who's somewhere in the
audience and what we've got second one
of the one of the one of the other
things we're doing in cog is trying to
localize sound so we we see motions we
cicada motions we learn that sort of
mapping and layers in the superior
colliculus in a human besides the visual
motion map that's coming in the
oculomotor map there's also a sound
aural map and we learn that coordination
between being a versa cade to where
sound is and from hearing the sound when
you put that on this robot suddenly it
starts to appear to be a lot more
engaged
so it's stating to - we're here sound
now hopefully there's gonna be oh yeah
okay now watch its eyes you can watch
the videos in the back as they talk it's
it's they're looking back and forth
between the two people having a
conversation and for a turn observe I
see that it looks like they're looking
back and forth it seems to be engaged in
understanding what's going on in that in
that conversation even though it's not
understanding any steep sense but we as
as human observers sort of are willing
to grant it that that license that is
doing this higher level thing so
emotional content may often be in the
eye of the observer and the level of
engagement may often be in the eye of
the observer and the observer as we saw
with the earlier videotape with Cynthia
Farrell was playing with that with the
eraser with the robot back and forth
becomes a component of the dynamics of
the behavior of the robot and we as
humans seem to be built to sort of time
that help give the benefit of the doubt
to systems that look biological and to
assume that they're engaged much more
than they maybe are so as our systems
become more complex engagement we
longer-term
and the illusion will be shattered less
often let me let me give you a quote
from sherry turkle's latest book life on
the screen sherry came over to our lab
and this is actually a couple of years
ago and when she walked in this is from
a book she said called noticed me soon
after an endless room its head turned to
follow me and I was embarrassed to note
that this made me happy I found myself
competing with another visitor for its
attention at one point I felt sure that
Coggs eyes had caught my own by the way
the colors here are mine not hers in the
book my visit left me shaken not by
anything that cog was able to accomplish
because you know it's just a few fairly
simple feedback loops but by my own
reaction to him for years whenever she'd
heard rodney brooks speak about his
robotic creatures i'd always been
careful to mentally put quotation marks
around the world but now with cog I'd
found the quotation marks had
disappeared
despite myself and this is the important
thing despite myself she's a skeptic and
despite my continuing skepticism about
this research project I had behaved as
though in the presence of another being
so it seems to me that as we build these
systems whether or not we put juice in
them because that's just my personal
belief that they need this juice they
will appear more and more to us to be to
have emotions maybe they've got this
emergent emotional thing going on maybe
that's been designed into them to force
that to happen to us and we will get
ourselves to the point where we want to
attribute to the system's things such as
fear when viewed in its complete context
a robot can be just as afraid as a
person well we're all willing to say
robots a person sorry can be afraid them
chimpanzee can they be afraid yeah dog
certainly seem to be afraid Birds yeah
lids needles well have that's might the
dust mites get afraid I think I think
it's and they build out of the same
stuff as us I think it I think it gets
down to the level of empathy that we're
willing to give these
so it's going to take us another
intellectual leap to get beyond their
own fears of this lack of specialness in
the order that we can finally admit such
possibilities you know some people will
claim that even a chimpanzee can have no
no feelings no fear but I think most the
common belief these days is somewhere
around here is where fear and pain and
things go away
so once machines can be afraid they'll
certainly have souls once we once we're
willing to admit they're afraid then I
think we'll have to be willing to admit
they have souls
in just the same way people have souls
see this in my little trick here because
I don't really believe people have souls
so in the same way you all believe that
people have souls you'll have to believe
that about machines back but here's a
question of what what what
[Music]
okay but I do worry I do worry
what can machines legitimately be afraid
of you know biological systems have had
an information content locked in to
ourselves so what we have until recently
this may change for us too
but in robots that information content
can be located off board at least that
the equivalent of a genetic material so
there's not this you know Darwinian
evolution had this urgency to make us be
self-preserving because that's where all
you know there wasn't the data bank over
there which had our stuff if we got
killed we died then our biological Jean
material died so Darwinian evolution had
to invent the need for fear and
incidentally souls but our robots are
not necessarily based on Darwinian
evolution it's one Norman evolution I
made that up but it seems to me that
that you know we can reproduce the robot
from this master copy it's a different
sort of evolution than then Darwinian
evolution so robots may not have to be
afraid in the long term and they could
be nasty if they don't have to be afraid
if they don't have to be self-preserving
they could be rather nasty different
aliens but if we need to nudge them if
they're complex systems and if we build
robots that need nurturing to develop as
a lot of people are standing to work on
because we think that with the
embodiment that's the only way we're
going to get to the right information
content inside the head of the current
robot which will be very dependent on
that robot its physical embodiment and
the world that inter interacted in to
get there we'll feel we have some
investment in them
well instill them with fear so that I
would go off and do silly things and get
hurt and their culture rate about will
irrationally just as ours
as I was talking about earlier this
jewel belief system continuing to
instill that fear in future generations
and finally we will have built worthy
successes to ourselves and I'll take
questions I guess
[Applause]
yeah maybe I think I think David shame
is you know fundamental type of
consciousness is also a field type
replacement but I just don't see any
evidence for the only evidence I have
for wanting this this juice which I
believe is some mathematical
construction is that I don't see the
current explanatory power of the gears
being enough to do it yeah
so maybe
seems a relic seem to let one subject
what do you think by that 29 inside so
why can't the robot head back is another
special well this is an explanation when
we put that we may be missing
that's a John Searle argument that's the
special stuff that makes people special
therefore and since the robots don't
have that they can't be people it's that
same circular argument that John cell
makes you want it to be special for
humans and you're defining it to be
special and including it special you're
just a bunch of will molecules messing
about and it's only because I've got
this this other dualistic notion that I
don't just come and squash you and I
don't see why that we can't be feel the
same way about our machines and have
that jewel a chip you want to have you
want to have the specialness be a little
box in there yeah it's it's it's the
homunculus argument again and I don't
buy it but I don't expect us to be I'd
agree on I don't think John Searle and I
can ever agree or not because he's stuck
in his set of dogmatic beliefs and I'm
stuck in mine yeah
use Microsoft it's too cheap I don't I
think we booming Seth complex systems
would talk any longer look for the
exponent rate level what we used to be
able to yeah we could we could build in
that it should be nice to people and
clean up the trash we can build on it as
a drive
am i chases they might change things
after a while but we could make out for
sales feel good for a while by doing
that oh yeah but I feel I have to look
after my kids for a while under get them
through college stuff like that yeah in
fact this you know there's been recent
papers in about why why why why do human
women live so long after menopause and
there's been a bunch of recent papers
about the grandmothers you know don't
aren't burdened with their own children
and they can continue and hope
[Applause]
yeah yeah I think I agree with this
perhaps cargo cultish sort of thing
building the physical body so it has the
same sorts of experiences because then
we think it's going to turn out to be
the same and we'll be happier in fact
these experiences
probably the the the the version I used
was based on it not being cargo cult
stuff yeah so yeah but so so I I think
we're still right in building the human
form I think that's why you know
dolphins are aliens to us we don't
really understand because they're not
they're not experiencing the world in
the same way so I I may be wrong but but
but but I think but my car will do
transportation it won't do it in the
same way as a horse doesn't and so it's
a level of abstraction argument if if if
we're willing to accept that you can
simulate something at a different with a
different level of abstraction without
going all the way down then I think you
have to admit the possibility that this
might work the guarantee is not is a
much harder thing
our offices are a few feet of pop so you
okay I've been involved in soccer on
both sides
maybe maybe at the time here those want
those a hand back there for a while
I don't know juice I think the juice is
at a totally different level from from
from folk psychology but but the
question of what I hope to achieve by
building COG a couple of things
certainly I don't expect that that by
itself is gonna make the juice pop out
the juice is an intellectual thing but a
totally different sort of investigation
by building the humanoid robot we get to
do a few things we get to play with
people's scientific psychological
theories and try and implement them on
the robot and find out how they fall
down what pieces are missing because
most psychological theories are actually
built in fairly isolation they connect
to a few conference papers and round
here and there but they don't have to
connect all the other pieces there's a
lot of hand waving it goes around so by
trying to put them together we find out
what's missing we also find out the
conclusions that may be made in the
experiments where someone has an
experiment and they have a certain
result and they say therefore it must be
the case that inside this six month old
infants head is or this particular set
of stuff if we can reproduce that
experiment without putting that stuff
inside the head of the robot then we can
get a negative result from psychological
theory so there's a negative
psychological results and then there's
the the thing of trying to find out
where the missing parts are as we put
stuff together yeah it's exactly what I
said
it's as live as you are in the future
as we create these robots
well very very few of us actually have
that therapy and my getting along so
[Music]
I thought about that there was a
question back there somewhere I don't
know how long are we supposed to be
going on here Hana 1 4 5 for 10 more
minutes if you want to we will make
certain assumptions there's built-in
dogmatic assumptions we're not willing
to admit to it and that's how we have
our scientific explanation of to
ourselves I don't see why that can't be
the same for the robots push had your
hand up for a while you know this is
this you know this this old guy who
thinks that maybe there's just missing
one critical thing and it's this it's
just like the idea of computation
cutting something different if only we
had that then you know oh yeah but but
why as good as computation would help us
for a long time yeah
humans or living things are
deterministic well you mean you
certainly you certainly see that that
even you know in a lot of the basic
biochemistry there's a lot of quantum
tunneling and stuff like that so is that
deterministic that's a that's a tricky
question this I think this this this
deterministic thing that was a bit of a
canard it's certainly what Joe Adelman
got stuck on and you know he said the
problem with these digital computers is
they're deterministic so he you know had
a robot this is when he was at NYU
before he moved that San Diego had a
Cray supercomputer to run it and he put
a pseudo-random number generator on the
computer so is no longer deterministic
he writes this in the book and therefore
now it's beyond normal computation but
it was a standard pseudo number
pseudo-random number generator so I
actually I should I think I think Lin
Lin Stein's talk is going to be about
that topic right on no no yeah so I'll
put it off till later in the series
three weeks yeah yeah
[Music]
well no in fact in fact my embodiment
approach sort of argues against that but
there's certainly a lot of people in AI
marvin minsky hands mario maker to to
name some who talk about downloading the
information content of the human brain
into some other form and therefore
continuing existence and this is in
their quest for eternal life which is
you have another dogmatic religious sort
of belief i don't know we're not under
the pressures of evolution we might be
on alert weak things in a different way
and not have that it depends it seems to
me on how much of the physical
experiences the robot has in the world
to develop itself depend on the details
of its particular mechanical
instantiation and these are the first
you know i tricky tricky questions i
don't know yeah
no I
that's a good point I think we will have
succeeded in making it something when we
feel bad about switching off we don't
feel bad about switching it off right
now that that little doll what you saw
you know you give it to a kid and first
off they're scared of it but after you
know someone shows them they start
playing with it and they're very careful
with it but you know one of the adults
well the engineers who built it like me
come up to it and we just grab it by its
feet and waving around the show how I
said it gets right so it depends on how
how engaged to be come with it what we
built so far with cog it's not engaging
enough to have to make any of these
sorts of things happen but in principle
I don't see why given this given my
dogmatic belief of a mechanistic
explanation for everything I don't see
why that cannot happen but we're not
there yet I agree yeah
yeah doesn't mean that I think many
people and scientists and all of us do
have these dual systems that we operate
in and and so I'm not I'm not worried
about that because I feel like I I for
instance and I'm already operating in
that jeweler so I don't see that as a
great problem
accrue them rights or do we just kind of
say well you know we made you you know
whatever I think I think that gets to
this point I must been careful how we
built them and I think I used up the
extra five or ten minutes so rot thank
you so much it was a wonderful card
[Applause]